if you think about what makes up who we
are so obviously there's genetics and
that makes up a percentage of how we see
the world and how we show up but then
the rest of it we're trained on to see
the world of certain way so there are
certain people that have something
called a negativity bias and a
negativity bias is nothing more than
they see the negative first it's not
that they don't see the positive but
they see the negative First there's
other people who see positive first they
have a positivity bias then they see
that first and the truth is in almost
every situation in every circumstance
there's both you can train somebody to
recognize that there's always both just
like every insight has an outside every
one side of a coin has another side of a
coin every up has a down if the way you
naturally are is negativity biased first
great be aware of that then flip over we
call it flip the switch so if one side
of your brain is going negativity first
great learn to flip the switch go great
what's the positive the side of that
that's a skill you can learn no
differently than playing tennis or chess
or music you can choose at any moment
positivity you can choose at any moment
gratitude you can choose at any moment
service you can choose to change your
mindset in in an instant if you wanted
to the challenge is we're so living in
our subconscious mode that we don't we
don't catch it soon enough we don't
think the action that we're proud of and
then we regret it you know we regret it
later on this morning I woke up really
early I'm very tired I woke up at 3 45
a.m for some reason don't know why uh
look at my look at my watch like 3 45
a.m what oh man okay try to go back to
sleep toss turn for about an hour and
then I got up like okay you know at 12
45 it's almost five you know let's let's
get up and I got to work and started
doing things and then the the crash hit
me
the crash hit me just not enough sleep
and everything inside me wanted to shut
down you know I wanted to just take a
complete break not do my walk in the
morning not not take the dogs out while
the dogs have to go out but not do my
routine not do any of my usual stuff not
record videos today's a Tuesday we're
gonna record it's video recording day
and it's in these moments those trying
times that you have to decide who you
want to be you have to decide if you
want to choose to be positive choose to
live in gratitude choose to live in
productivity choose live in service or
not what would the future you think of
your actions right now
and I think 95 of the time the answer is
to push a little harder move the brake
line forward right where where you would
normally take a break move that forward
just a little bit move the brake line
forward a touch
and five percent of the time you have to
be more gentle on yourself
when my family dog passed away when I
broke my neck when you know all sorts of
things have happened to me just like
they've happened to you sometimes the
answer is to give yourself a little more
grace
to recognize how far you've come
everything that you've done with the
limited amount of resources and time
that you have
but I think if we default to that then
we default to staying stuck and staying
small because life is going to throw so
many different challenges at you
so I think 95 of the time that's the
five percent right five percent of time
you give yourself more grace you let
yourself off the hook you take the day
off you do whatever you need especially
if you're struggling with grief
if you're struggling with grief I think
you just have to work your way through
it you have to give yourself a lot of
Grace and a lot of time and and it will
get better and and just please don't go
through it alone
but almost everything else
usually the answer is to keep going
because it'll make you more proud
because you're teaching yourself that
you stand up to obstacles then you
overcome
so this morning I woke up I got out of
bed I was instantly productive like okay
I'm wired for whatever reason here we go
let's go answering my Discord messages
if you're not on Discord Evan
carmichael.biz I'm there every morning
it's super fun answering questions it's
such a great community so I did my
Discord I looked at the responding to my
emails and Twitter and
um I got all my work done super early
then the crash hits and then Nina wakes
up
and it's time to make videos and
I don't want to make videos
you know I'm I'm tired I feel like I'm
gonna let myself down and I feel like
I'm Gonna Let You Down is the honest
answer not that I don't want to make
videos because I don't enjoy them I feel
like it won't be at my best and then I
won't I won't create something that I'm
proud of and I'm gonna let you guys down
that's really the internal narrative you
know I'm gonna create a subpar product
and people who watch are gonna be
disappointed because
I take it as a big responsibility that
you know some of you start your day
every day with one of my videos that
means a lot to me it's not a burden but
a responsibility that I take and I want
to make something that I'm proud of and
that helps you improve your life today
at least gives you a little kick start
you know like let's go let's have a
great day I want to be able to bring
that energy and and I I was worried that
this morning I wouldn't be able to do it
but you know what that's not a good
enough reason
it's not a good enough reason
as long as you believe those reasons
you will never create anything great
because if you wait to have the right
energy the perfect timing the right
amount of sleep the the perfect cell
phone or video camera with the perfect
microphone and you know
just it will never happen you will never
create anything great
and so I had to remind myself of that
because you can choose positivity at any
moment you can choose service you can
choose gratitude you can choose
productivity at any moment you can
choose it if you want to if you really
want to you can instead of defaulting to
the negative patterns and so Nina got up
I told her I was tired told I had a
rough night she said she slept super
well
it's like oh that's really that's really
bad but I slept so well like great well
I'm very happy for you but I'm very
tired right now and
um
right away then asked okay so when are
when are we going out
because Nina's shopping at Costco I mean
I'm in the Costco parking lot I think
you can't make content like I'm sitting
here in the Costco parking lot filming
videos for you guys and I asked her when
are we going out when are you gonna when
do you want to go shopping because I'm
gonna get my phone ready and I'm gonna
make some videos
and in that instant I decided and then
committing to her made it happen
and here I am in the car making the
videos happen and hopefully there's
there's something good and I'm not
disappointing you guys but I'm making
myself proud at the very least
when you show up when the world's
against you or when you've had a rough
day or when you don't feel like it or
when you got a nasty comment or you're
in a weird mood for whatever reason you
still show up like when it's hard when
it's hard and you still show up
is when you build the most self-love and
self-belief
self-confidence that's where it comes
from doing difficult things
and what it does is it reinforces that
as your identity
that this is who you become
so the next time something comes up you
can handle it aim a little bit more
because they're moving the brake line
forward
it's a really slippery slope to fall
down that every time you come up against
something difficult you don't do it
even if other people are telling you how
great you are that you can do it if you
tell yourself that you can't do it then
the next time it comes up you reinforce
it you can't do it and you can't do it
and you can't do it and what you've
built is an automatic pattern of you
don't follow through that you can't do
it that when you set a goal you're not
going to follow through on it you know
you're going to start and then you're
going to stop that when something gets
hard you know you're going to give up on
it or that you're going to quit in a
couple days because that's the pattern
that you've built for yourself and the
pattern becomes the identity
right if you want to switch your
identity it's totally possible
the person who always follows through
you could be the person who always steps
up you can be the person who always
delivers you could be the person who
always brings it best you could be that
person you may not believe that yet but
you can be that person so how do you get
there
how does that become your new identity
there are two things that really matter
first is to be around other people who
are like that
one of the reasons why I was able to get
up and do this today was because
I watch John Assaraf and Steve Jobs and
Oprah Winfrey and these people every day
now I happen to know John astraff he's
become a friend uh I don't know Steve
Jobs or Oprah Winfrey
um I don't know Oprah yet so we'll see
Steve I've missed my chance
but
hanging around them even if it's
virtually even if you you don't know who
John you don't you can't call him up and
ask him a question or you can't call up
Oprah great you can still learn from
them you can still be around them and
the more that you see other people doing
things the more you want to go do it
yourself have you ever been to a movie
and you got inspired and you see
somebody win the race like the underdog
you like I love the Underdog Story you
ever seen Underdog go off and win and
then it makes you want to go not run a
race but do your thing like you've ever
been inspired by somebody else's
overcoming of obstacle story
right
so it's the same thing if you're around
successful people
and you see how they're doing it and you
see how they rise up against the
obstacles in their in their life it
gives you encouragement and hope and
belief that you can too where most of
the people that we're surrounded by
are already giving up they gave they're
not even trying they gave up years ago
right and so when we're at our weakest
moments
when we're around people are consuming
content that reinforces our negative
beliefs
the people say okay yeah yeah just take
a break yeah don't do this you weren't
meant to do this anyway like why did you
think you could ever do this just go and
and play a computer game or just go and
watch some you know trash TV right
just gonna get distracted for the day
pretend like you're doing stuff but you
know you're not doing anything that's
going to make you proud right just
scroll through Instagram all day like
everybody else right when you're around
that then it's so easy for you to fall
down that rabbit hole when you're not at
your A-game so you can you can
manufacture it by being around the
people again if you don't know them
personally then just in your environment
some videos you watch is why it's why I
make this content that I can introduce
you to people and and keep bringing you
ideas and belief that hopefully inspires
you daily to lift you up when when you
might be having a rough day
so that's step one step two is you have
to then do something people say
motivation doesn't last well that's true
but
the point of motivation isn't for it to
last the point of motivation is to give
you the courage to go do the thing so
I'm I'm waking up this morning early
right Nina's still sleeping she wakes up
but before she wakes up while I'm doing
my work while I'm hanging on Discord
first the discord's super fun and
connect with entrepreneurs and so it's
it's already getting me in in a good
mood
and then I started watching videos from
my own top 10 Channel
so as I'm working I've got who I listen
to today
um I had Bill Gates on
uh we'll head to Bezos on
uh I had an old Richard Branson one on
and their voices are are in my head as
I'm working and so then when Nina gets
up it's like okay let's go let's go to
work because I had Richard Branson and
Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates in my ear this
morning right and I don't know any of
them personally
and so you could do that too right but
the whole point of that motivation is
then to give you the courage to go Act
so by listening to them in the morning
listen to them is not enough right
that's not enough you got all inspired
and motivated to not do anything
listen to them then gave me the boldness
to say Evan you need to make videos
today you said you're gonna do it let's
go do it I know you're afraid of
disappointing people you're gonna make
it the best you can let's go
because I imagine what would Bill Gates
tell me what would Jeff Bezos tell me
what would Richard Branson tell me they
tell me something like that I think I
hope I don't think they're gonna say you
know what just quit
probably not right
and then that got me to go out and now
I'm here and I'm making the content I'm
doing the thing
so it's the motivation that you need to
inject into yourself
plus the action
and when you do that enough you start to
build the new habit so instead of the
pattern being I don't follow through I
always quit I always get up you start to
build a new pattern that says I rise to
the occasion I overcome these obstacles
I defeat that little voice inside my
head I called the little man I beat the
little man
right and when you do that consistently
then that becomes your new default
pattern that the next challenge that
comes in you say okay let's go what's
next I'm ready I want the next Mountain
let's go climbing right
so it's totally possible but it starts
with the belief that at any point
you can choose positivity at any point
you can choose gratitude at any point
you can choose service no matter what's
going on in your life right now there
are millions of people who have it way
worse than you
and you can choose
the light and you can choose to help
and you can choose to inspire and doing
that will not only serve the world but
make you a lot more proud of yourself
too
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
we have to understand that our beliefs
Drive our Behavior our habits Drive our
Behavior well what if we switched
our beliefs what if we switched our
habits what if we upgraded the knowledge
and skill required to match the income
that we want so there's something I'm
going to leave you with right
and that is this
in order to achieve two or three or four
times more income and get your brain
unlocked you have to create an identity
to match that Destiny you have to create
an identity to match that Destiny of the
income and the lifestyle and the
feelings that you want if you think
about what makes up who we are so
obviously there's genetics those are
genetic makeups our pre-disposition our
propensities and that makes up a
percentage of how we see the world and
how we show up but then the rest of it
we're trained on so we're trained to see
the world of certain way so there are
certain people that have something
called the negativity bias and a
negativity bias is nothing more than
they see the negative first it's not
that they don't see the positive but
they see the negative First there's
other people who see positive first they
have a positivity bias then they see
that first and the truth is in almost
every situation in every circumstance
there's both
you can train somebody to recognize that
there's always both just like every
insight has an outside every one side of
a coin has another side of a coin every
up has a down that's called The Law of
polarity and in the universe that we
live in there is that law of polarity
and so you can teach somebody say okay
if you're propensity if the way you
naturally are is negativity biased first
great be aware of that then flip over we
call it flip the switch so if one side
of your brain is going negativity first
great learn to flip the switch go great
what's the positive side of that that's
a skill you can learn no differently
than playing tennis or chess or music
when you sit down to meditate do you
come with an intention then each time
um no I I I
um when once I sit down then I ask my
intuition hey what is it that you want
to be doing today what is it that you
today so we all have this intuition
which is different than our Instinct but
this intuition right it's what we know
before we think
and so when I sit down and say okay
um hey uh what's what's the intention
for today and sometimes the intention is
to just let go and see what happens
sometimes the intention is I'm searching
for you know for an answer uh sometimes
the intention is well today Focus you
know today let go today just breathe so
I just listen I just it's just it's it's
the the art and the subtle signs of
paying attention back in 1987 when I
bought the franchising rights for Remax
of Indiana
um I have no idea how to build a company
I was you know 26 years old and um but I
had another Mentor who I invested 75 000
to become his partner to have the
opportunity to learn from this man who
at the time was worth probably 100
million dollars and so I was very very
uh keen on learning and I didn't know
how to build a business I didn't know
anything other than how to sell real
estate and I said a goal to generate one
billion dollars a year in sales and I
set the goal for five years in the
future not knowing
a billion dollar goals like
mind-boggling big for me and I there was
an interview
um the second week I was in Indianapolis
I moved from Toronto to Indianapolis for
this opportunity and um I was
interviewed by the Indianapolis Business
Journal and I said uh in the interview
that was at a goal for a billion dollars
and the reporter said are you aware that
there's two companies that have been in
the state of Indiana for 80 years 100
years the other one and they haven't hit
a billion dollars in real estate sales
in all of these years and I said yeah I
know it's Graves and Tucker and you can
let them know that I'll be the first
right and as I said that I almost felt
like I put my foot right in my mouth
because I didn't know how I was gonna do
it right long story short five years
later we sold enough franchise recruit
enough agents we did 1.2 billion dollars
and we were we were stuck which is a
great place to be stuck and I was asking
myself how is it possible that I'm
training these agents with strategies
with tactics with selling skills
marketing skills we were like the gurus
of here's the books here's the cassettes
here's the trainers here's like out of
the deep end and the agents who for
example would make thirty thousand
dollars a year kept making 30 000 a year
the agents who made 50 kept making 50.
they actually made 100 kept making a
hundred and so I realized that they
weren't missing the skills or the
knowledge there was something else at
play and what helped me from the age of
19 to 27 28 30 was every single day and
I still do it today and I'll share this
with with you in just a little bit every
single day I was priming my brain with
the beliefs and the self-image required
to achieve the goals that I want when we
talk about reprogramming
I think the the important thing to
understand is
99.9 of what we think what we feel and
what we do although most people think
I'm in control I'm the one doing it it's
really non-conscious patterns that are
repeating themselves over and over again
so let me explain when you and I were
born
the only neural networks that we had
were for survival right we didn't have
any beliefs of are we good enough are we
smart enough are we worthy we didn't
have any experiences to show us that
that's a scary situation that one's not
snakes are safe or snakes are dangerous
or spiders or Heights or whatever the
case is so over the course of the first
seven to ten years of our life our
brain's plasticity switch our brains
switch that connects all of these
neurons and creates the neural map in
our brain is is being created in the
form of millions of connections per
second by time we're 10 or 12 years old
that switch basically goes off and now
there's more selective okay creation of
neural patterns based on what we like
what we dislike what we experience what
our parents tell us what our teachers
tell us up until that time we're just an
empty Open Nest where everything's being
formulated and so what happens is after
you know 10 12 years old we're pretty
much running on autopilot and we become
conditioned or trained to see the world
a certain way to feel certain things to
behave in certain ways and so most of
our life we're working on autopilot
because the non-conscious processing
parts of our brain is working at you
know 400 billion bits of information per
second and trillions of electrical and
chemical reactions per second having
without our thinking about it and so for
adults you know 25 35 45 50
we have these patterns that we have to
revamp almost like a remodeling of our
own brains if you think about you know
when you're driving in a town that you
know whether you're at home or in your
city that you know and all of a sudden
you see a detour if you take a detour
and then you start driving down that new
DeTour for a day seven days two weeks
three weeks four weeks that detour
becomes the new easy road to take even
though you're used to going a certain
way the brain works the exact same way
so if you've got these patterns that are
easy for you your brain wants to take
those patterns that are easy for easy
thinking patterns easy emotional
patterns easy behavioral patterns why
number one because it's less energy that
the brain needs to to use so law of best
use of energy in the brain is where it
goes first
so the way you retrain your brain using
for example the 4r process is you
recognize my patterns of thought my
patterns of emotion my patterns of
behaviors and yourself are these going
to help me achieve the goal that I want
to achieve whatever the goal is it's
just yes or no if they are great if
they're not then what you want to be
doing is saying okay how do I change
that path how do I change my thinking
I'm learning that I could be still I'm
learning that I could be aware of my
thoughts but then let them go and I come
back to focus on a sound wave in this
particular meditation and then what
happens is over a period of practice you
realize that your basically your body
disappears you're no longer in this
physical thing you're no longer having
these waves of thought after thought
after thought after thought after
thought after idea positive negative and
everything in between
and in that space of recognizing that
I'm not my physical body I have a
physical body I'm not my thoughts I have
thoughts I'm not my emotions I have them
when you start to train yourself to use
your brain better
more efficiently more productively you
realize that a I am one with this you
know Incredible Universe so what's the
big deal about that well the big deal is
that if I am one with this universe with
this energy with everyone and everything
and that's where everything percolates
from is it possible that all my answers
are right here right now anyway
and the answer is yeah and so meditation
is about practicing and we know that we
have uh different brain waves so right
now as people are watching or listening
you know they're in this beta brainwave
frequency where their brain is
oscillating at a certain frequency and
there's 50 different brain waves going
on at any given time but what happens is
when I move into from beta to Alpha to
Theta Delta or gamma I'm actually
accessing and activating different parts
of my brain which now gives me this
deeper greater sense of awareness of of
much bigger you know onion that I'm used
to seeing so I'm living on a layer of an
onion and what if I could see like 10
layers up and 10 layers Downs all of a
sudden it's like wow look at who I am
what I am who you are what you are and
in that realization in that awareness I
can now start to have different Choice
choices May need and so meditation is a
practice
of awareness it's a practice of going
internal instead of external which is
where most people live their lives every
day so the key
is to really understand first and
foremost that you have a brain you're
not your brain the whole idea with inner
size right is to create
um a pathway for you to be able to say
okay here's how my brain works simply as
I've put it today and here's what I
could do about it to move out of a state
of chaos and dissonance and into a state
of coherence and Alignment so when you
were born were you born with any beliefs
no were you born with any habits no were
you born with any fears no no so from a
neuroscience a neuropsychology
perspective a belief is nothing more
than this imagine that you're born and
your brain is made up of a 100 billion
Marbles and every time you have an
experience or somebody says something to
you you read something or you watch
something these marbles make these
connections and the connections that are
reinforced go from conscious connections
to subconscious connections and once
these subconscious connections are made
and reinforced they run the show 98 of
the time so a belief is nothing more
than a reinforced pattern in the brain
and our conscious brain can choose what
we want when we're in that uh part of
our brain but our subconscious mind
can't choose its program from the age of
zero three uh in the imprinting years
three to about seven or eight the
modeling years and then eight on it's
the experiential years and so if you
have these uh powerful beliefs that
you're good enough you're smart enough
you're worthy to achieve the goals that
you have
um if you have these powerful leads you
are able to achieve any amount of income
you choose no matter what the amount is
you just need to learn how so if you
have these empowering beliefs you have
brain coherence between conscious and
subconscious we're in in a society that
just goes goes goes goes goes goes goes
texts emails phone calls Facebook
Twitter Vine all these things are
keeping us on this Perpetual hamster
wheel of doo doo doo doo doo that very
few people stop up and say what am I
doing what am I not doing what am I
thinking what am I feeling so the first
part is stop
second part is to reframe
it's called a 4r process recognizes
first reframe is the way I'm looking at
something and because we are monofocused
the brain cannot focus consciously on
more than one thing at a time
all right you can get distracted to that
thing then this thing then that thing
then this thing the art of multitasking
is actually one of the worst things that
you can do from a neurological
perspective Highly Successful People are
able to Mono focus on the right things
so when you learn to reframe your
brain's ability to look at this then
look at this then look at this but stay
focused on what it is that you're
looking at you see different
perspectives of it the next part is to
release
the emotional stress that most people's
brains are under how do we get into this
emotional stress well when we have fears
there's 50 different types of fears for
your success for your failure fear of
disappointment fear of being embarrassed
fear of being ashamed fear of being
ridiculed fear of fill in the blank when
our brain goes on these automatic fear
circuit drives then we're in a state of
fight or flight in a state of fight or
flight over a course of a day a week a
month our ability to actually use our
Thinking Center the left prefrontal
cortex of our brain actually diminishes
our brain gets hijacked into this fight
or flight response system over and over
and over and over and over again and
that response system is actually pretty
healthy initially to get you going and
out of the gate but if you are always in
this fight or flight response mechanism
you're on this hamster wheel deal you
actually start to get burnt out and you
can't think you can't use the genius
part of your brain you can't really
activate the part of you that connects
to the entire universe of intelligence
within you and outside of you and so you
learn to release that tension
to be able to put the foot back on the
gas change the gear if you think about
what happens
when you're driving a stick shift car
you put your foot on the gas in first
gear and the car just goes but if you
keep your foot on the gas in first gear
you're going to burn out the engine
so what happens in the release part of
using your brain is you go from first
gear pause second gear pause third gear
pause you're able to use the engine more
efficiently to go faster exact same
thing with our brains if we learn how to
release the tension and switch gears
release the tension switch gears that's
the art of release and go and that
causes the fourth R and that's we
retrain our brain to operate at higher
levels of our intelligence genius and
abilities what happens
if at the subconscious level okay so you
have conscious goal conscious Vision
conscious reasons why I want to achieve
it what happens if at the subconscious
level let's say for weight
you try to lose weight before and maybe
you have but then you've gained it back
what if you've done that three or four
or five or six times is that pattern
okay the memory the pattern locked in
the subconscious mind of all those
experiences is it there so here's how
the brain works
you set a goal using the left prefrontal
cortex of your brain your imagination
and then right after you set the goal
and you're excited because you're you're
making some progress
your brain says hey
um last time you did this uh you gained
all the weight back
why even try
uh last time you did this and your
friends saw that you did this and then
you gained all the weight back next time
you saw them you were embarrassed uh you
were a little ashamed of yourself last
time you did this or the three or four
or five or six times before that
um you gained all the weight back and uh
you disappointed yourself and your
significant other because you know they
said you looked really great and then
you gained all the weight back so you
disappointed them uh and yourself and
you were embarrassed or ashamed
um and so
that pattern is there right do you all
agree with me so far the pattern is
there and so if you have and think about
your imagination and your your your your
choice to set a goal is one pattern that
you formulate but if underneath there's
a sub cop there's a subconscious pattern
of embarrassment shame failure guilt
disappointment
Etc if that pattern is also there then
you have two opposing patterns you have
one pattern that says let's go and do
this but you have another pattern it
says but last time you did this you
failed or you've seen your sister or
brother or mother or father or friend do
this and guess what they gained all the
weight back anyway so why even try I'm
going to keep you safe in your comfort
zone I'm gonna conserve energy
and uh that way I'm gonna save you some
time and money and energy
does that make sense you that is called
cognitive dissonance that is another way
of saying that's called chaos in the
brain and a brain in chaos will do what
it'll just stick around doing the things
that it's comfortable doing where it's
known something that I learned I think
people will benefit from is an anxiety
attack stress uh Panic
ulcerative colitis all of these things
are effects
right so their effects so the question
is what's the cause yes right so most
people are focusing on either you know
suppressing the effects
um depressing the effects
um masking the effects they're doing
everything but going what's causing this
and if we look at the world of cause
whether it's in our physical body
whether it's our relationship whether
it's our bank account whether it's our
business whatever the result is every
result in the physical world is an
effect
so the question is what causes the
results and one of the greatest laws in
the universe is the law of cause and
effect and states that for every effect
there's a cause and for every cause
there's an effect and so I got really
inquisitive and curious early on with
can I control more of the cause of my
results and that required responsibility
and when I was younger I was like I was
more into the blame game it's because of
him because of her because of it because
of the market because of where I live
because of my mother my father how old I
am or how young I am how Asian or
Caucasian I am it doesn't make a
difference so a lot of my upbringing
caused me to look outside of myself and
when I looked inside myself and took the
I guess the
prerequisite of responsibility I own it
yes I can change it that transformed my
life that you know that really started
to to put things into perspective so
when we talk about the word fear right
so let me let me start off with another
you know little premise here is um
most people are highly ignorant in
understanding what fear is
now I want to make sure people heard me
correctly ignorance doesn't mean you are
stupid ignorance means you just don't
know we're all ignorant we don't know
what we don't know well we don't know we
don't know and even the things that we
do know may not be accurate so when we
talk about fear there are 50 different
types of fear
all fear all fear is processed in the
subconscious mind
the automatic
neurochemistry that is created as a
result of the meaning that we give
certain things that cause us to either
be in a state or a fear or a stage of a
state of courageousness is all being
processed in our subconscious mind so
what causes fear for you doesn't cause
fear for me or for somebody else or may
cause fear in other people so whether
you know we're standing at the you know
top of a building that's a hundred
stories high some people look over and
don't have fear and other people do have
fear whether there's a giant 10-foot boa
constrictor you know in front of you may
cause fear in you that doesn't cause
fear in another person so it's never the
thing
that is causing the fear it's the
subconscious interpretation that we've
been conditioned to believe the meaning
that we learn to give something
determines whether the neurochemistry of
fear is activated that causes us to feel
a certain way so the feeling okay of of
being scared the feeling of being
uncertain this feeling of having
self-doubt the feeling of uh um of
having too much stress in our life that
is an effect
not a cause so feelings are conscious
our ability to be aware of this stuff
that's going on in our body that we
either know or don't know how to handle
or do anything with yeah so feeling is
conscious
fear is subconscious and so if for
example
we have you know one of the examples I
use is and you don't have this obviously
but if I ask a hundred people you know
do you have a fear of public speaking I
was just going to say that or so I was
just gonna say that I'm reading your
mind I'm reading your mind well it's not
your fear and that's what I'm going to
say so the actual fear is of being
embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or judged
so if we're afraid of being embarrass
the shame ridiculed or judged that has
nothing to do with the actual public
speaking it has to do with our
self-image and self-esteem and what we
think of ourselves and what we believe
others will say or think about us which
will affect our own self-image or
self-esteem so fear is triggered based
on subconscious patterns and feelings of
certainty about something that may or
may not be right
and so I never treat you know if you if
you like animals you like fish for
example if the fish is sick you never
treat the fish you treat the water
yeah oh that's good I like that one you
treat the water yeah
um because it's the water that's causing
the fish to be sick and so whenever
we're dealing with fear fear is a signal
so if we're driving our car together
okay we're driving down the street and
all of a sudden there's a light that
pops up on your dash you're gonna go oh
my God the light came on no it's a
signal there's either something maybe
the trunk open maybe you're low on air
maybe there's a a leak in your oil maybe
your your coolant in your you know in
your engine needs topping up the the
light is just a signal that something in
the engine is going on so when we have
this emotion that's triggered okay at
the subconscious level that gives us
this feeling that we don't like or we
don't know how to deal with the light
goes on okay in our brain we start
experiencing those emotions we start
experiencing those emotions and so when
we get into so why is that relevant and
it's relevant because the number one
priority of the brain above all else
okay above sex above eating above glute
above all else is survival and safety
first so when that fear signal is
activated in the brain
your break goes on your motivation stops
your thinking brain deactivates and
you're either gonna fight it you're
gonna freeze you're gonna run away or
you're gonna faint those are the four
F's of fear what happens when that
response happens and to the untrained
person it controls them to the trained
person like a Navy SEAL like a
firefighter has to learn how to feel
fear and go into a burning building like
an astronaut she has to learn how to
step out of the space station and go
work with a robotic arm knowing that she
might be blown away into space
um she has fear fears as well he has
fears as well and so fear is just a
signal it's not a stop sign it's not a
ghost sign it's a be aware sign if you
think think about visualization is
simulation
now here is whoa that's good okay go
ahead so visualization is simulation so
when we close our eyes or even if our
eyes are open and we start to use our
Einstein brain the imagination we now
have just activated one of the biggest
centers of our brain the occipital lobe
that's connected to the motor cortex
it's connected to the motivational
Circle the nucleus comes that releases
that dopamine that makes you feel good
that makes you want to take action so if
you visualize yourself achieving the
goal if you visualize yourself behaving
in ways that match the new belief if you
even visualize the words or you take the
words on a sheet of paper and you read
them run your right finger across it run
your left finger across it close your
eyes see it and feel it your brain is
creating a mental movie with the words
and as it creates a mental movie with
the words that's happening in your
subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
Works number one is survival but then
number two is safety and then number
three is energy conservation now when
you do something 20 30 40 50 times it
takes about 66 days to 365 days of
repetition to override an old habitual
circuit not 10 days not 21 days 66 to
365. so if you visualize yourself
achieving the goal feeling the success
that you want to feel seeing the belief
on the screen of your mind you are
actually creating a neural network
through the science of neuroplasticity
and the networks that you reinforce
become the most dominant networks and
since your brain wants to conserve
energy if you do this on a consistent
basis your brain says okay you're doing
this so often let me just make this
automatic let me set aside the the old
beliefs let me replace it with the new
beliefs and now you've deliberately and
consciously evolved yourself one of the
things that is is really interesting I
mean just based on what you said there
is something in business whether it's
for sales people on the phones or sales
people in person on the phone it's
called call reluctance and in person
it's po it's called Contact reluctance
and so if you think about what does that
mean so I have a call reluctance I have
a reluctance to call somebody that I
don't know
and so when some people think about
calling somebody they don't know when
they're prospecting or meeting somebody
they don't know if you think about what
is it that is actually happening that
causes them to to feel that so as soon
as they have the thought their
neurochemistry kicks in because the
meaning that they have is if I call
somebody that I don't know and they hang
up on me they yell at me they say
something nasty to me then they are
attacking my identity and in most cases
they have Associated the attack on their
identity in a negative way
such as well maybe it's true that I'm
not good enough maybe it's true that I'm
not smart enough maybe it's true that
I'm not worthy so they have a negative
association with somebody's response
that they don't even know
about who they are so the first thing we
work on is let's focus on your
self-esteem
because the self-esteem that's being
attacked my self-esteem and self-worth
is being attacked so when my self-esteem
and self-worth is being attacked in a
negative way or unpleasant way I'm going
to process that as danger in my brain
now when you understand the brain's
number one responsibility is to move you
away from danger or pain that's number
one on its hierarchy of how it behaves
so if there is real or imagined pain or
discomfort your brain says stop put the
brakes on go the other way that's what's
happening so the first thing we do is we
teach people number one let's change the
meaning that you have around what
somebody else's response is
around who you are or what you're doing
or what you're offering them so the
first thing we work on is change the
meaning you change the feeling for the
people who think that the law of
attraction is
um you know think believe in your
achieve first I'm going to tell you
that's
so let's call them
um but I want you to think of your brain
just a little bit differently and think
of it this way let's say you love rock
and roll and let's say rock and roll is
on station 95.5 if you're on station
92.1 that might be classical
if you're on station 98.7 that might be
punk rock but a 92.5 that's rock and
roll
so imagine coherence just means locking
your electromagnetic spectrum of your
brain lock it and load it on exactly
what you want so what's the vision
what's the goal what are the beliefs
what are the emotions that create
coherence so you're locked and loaded to
the frequency of the universe that is
matching that goal part one part two is
when you get locked and loaded you've
actually activated the Einstein brain
connected to the motor cortex connected
to the dopamine release in your body
and when that happens okay now you're in
coherence but there's another part that
happens in this Einstein part of the
brain that's actually what the latest
neuroscientists and psychologists are
thinking is connected to this GPS part
of our brain to the frequency of where
all of the tools resources people are
that resonate with that
um frequency so
we've been evolving for what two and a
half million years since Homo erectus to
now 108 billion humans on Earth with a
brain that's been changing and growing
and my belief is we're just scratching
the proverbial surface and we talk about
you know a little quantum mechanics or
quantifies with entanglement how we're
all connecting we're all tuning into the
frequencies that are us and within us
and all around us now when we learn to
use our brain better uh it's just
mind-boggling how we can achieve goals
and dreams that we thought were
impossible to achieve before and this is
the fun part now I have a philosophy
that every moment every precious
nanosecond and moment is perfect
and so when I connect to the profession
of that moment there's really nothing to
do it's to be aware and to allow to
surrender but not to give up surrender
but to understand that you know as you
know we are talking right now
uh the oceans don't need any instruction
what to do the uh the um planets that
are moving in in their elliptical orbits
around the sun don't need yours or my
intervention the universe the Milky Way
galaxy that's you know flowing through
the universe at a million and a half
miles per hour doesn't need yours in my
instruction so that means that ever
every moment is perfect so I want to
connect to the Perfection of every
single moment be aware of that every
single moment and realize that many
things are not to my taste many things I
don't understand but that doesn't mean
that the moment isn't perfect every
human being has a relationship with
money and money is something that
um
envelops people's brains about what they
buy what they don't buy whether they buy
you know a business class or first class
or a regular economy seats whether
they're always looking for the cheapest
or the most expensive the nicest uh or
average how much they will tip how much
they won't we all have
a money story that we've developed
mostly from our parents and the people
that we live near and we developed this
relationship around money and our
beliefs around money you know are we
good enough to earn that amount uh are
we worthy enough to earn that amount
um uh is it is it um worth it or not and
so one of the things that Mary Morrissey
um says that um we should do she says
for seven days write down the thoughts
you have about money and notice when
you're thinking
um and notice what you are thinking and
notice that the money story you're
telling yourself is it positive negative
is it abundance thinking or limited
thinking is it scarcity thinking or is
it
but fill in the blank and so once you
know your money story and this is also
something that one of our um
psychiatrists who works with us Dr David
Krueger says once you know the story The
Money story that's when you can start to
be aware of it and go wow where did I
get these limiting beliefs about money
about my value where do I get these
limiting beliefs of what I can afford
and what I can't where do I get these
limiting beliefs around
um
um how I behave with money let's say you
have a car which I imagine most people
who are watching have a car imagine
you're driving your car
and a light comes on the dash
it's like oh I wonder what that light is
and you look a little bit closer and it
says there's a little you're low on oil
uh in the engine
okay so you're aware of that and the
light stays on and then two seconds
later another light comes on and you
know what's going on and it says that uh
the rear tire is low on air
you know what ah what was going on
and so you keep driving you say at the
next gas station I'm going to stop and
I'll fill up the air and um I'll put up
some oil in the um in the engine so that
I top everything up now why am I using
that example
when we have an emotion
all emotions every pay close attention
you have emotions you are not your
emotions emotions are different than
feelings emotions happen as a Autumn as
an automatic subconscious trigger
when your brain is evaluating something
you want to do or something that you are
doing against the memory that's in there
that's causing this old emotion of how
you felt or what you did or what you
were thinking or what you were
experiencing at the time that the memory
was created so all emotions are
processed at the subconscious level and
whatever pattern is associated with that
behavior that you're doing right now or
the incoming stimuli from the outside
world is going to trigger this emotion
which then sends a neurochemical release
that you feel as guilt and has the
thought patterns of guilt or the
emotions of being embarrassed the
feeling is the conscious awareness of
the cocktail of neurochemicals that have
been released but the emotion is
subconscious so
is it possible to recalibrate uh
neurological pattern in the brain is it
possible if a pattern is nothing more
than neurons that have been coalesced or
connected Can you interrupt a pattern
from the past is it possible to
interrupt a pattern from the past
so answer that question is it possible
to interrupt a pattern from the past
right so is it possible
is it possible of course it's possible
any pattern that exists in the brain is
nothing more than a group of neurons
brain cells that in many cases have 10
000 connections okay at the end of each
neuron that formulate this connectedness
between the neurons so you can interrupt
a pattern just like you can interrupt
and create a new habit you can interrupt
an emotional pattern a behavioral
pattern a a feeling pattern and you can
interrupt it using a variety of
methodologies you can take a pattern and
you can visualize it getting smaller you
can accentuate it with colors with uh
animal uh images with visualization with
meditation with mindfulness with
affirmation with subliminal programming
you can interrupt patterns and even more
important than that based on the latest
research on neuroplasticity you can
create a new pattern
and that becomes the new default pattern
the parts of the brain that register and
experience
versus the part of the brain that can
imagine an experience are not different
so if I imagine doing a bicep curl in my
mind I see my arm moving and I'm doing a
bicep curl in my mind I'm accessing the
occipital lobe part of my brain it is no
different than me going to the gym and
doing a bicep curl so when you do both
you solidify the experience even more
now I want to just talk about what you
just said about your partner who brings
in meditation when most people
are asked to do something that they're
fearful of the sympathetic nervous
system in the brain kicks in in
nanoseconds not in minutes and
nanoseconds that's the fight or flight
response system in the brain so they
want to run away or they freeze and they
can't do anything
but if you take that same experience
that you want them to do
and you have them do it in their mind
first in a calm state so first if you
have them visualize doing that and they
feel nervous but you just have to do one
little thing six breaths why six breaths
we know from the research now that if
you imagine in your mind doing something
that you're fearful of and you allow the
parasympathetic nervous system to rule
that means that you're going to be
shallow breathing you're going to raise
your blood pressure you're going to
activate your sweat glands and you're
going to activate all of the fight or
fear
response mechanism the fight or flight
response mechanisms and that is a very
tense
situation to be in what if you could
take somebody and have them imagine that
exact same thing but before they take
the action they see themselves they just
take 60 breaths one
see yourself doing it two three four
five six what happens is because you're
breathing deeply in and out your
parasympathetic nervous system okay
kicks in why because that is the relax
response mechanism in the brain so if
you consciously activate your relaxation
response mechanism
with something that would normally be
stressful for you you actually
deactivate the fear Center in the brain
the amygdala and you actually open up
your thinking Center of your brain the
genius part of your brain that could
actually override the fear center of the
brain it's a small little mechanism that
you can just learn how to do so I say
you do both
not one or learn both goes back to
upgrade your Knowledge and Skills of
saying why am I afraid which system of
mine you know is operating right now so
think about this when we walk into a
room we could flip the switch and turn
on the light because we want more light
well why not flip your own genius switch
why not flip off the switch of fear and
anxiety and stress and flip on the
switch of calmness certainty and
creativity there it's your switch
we just haven't been taught how to turn
one switch off and turn one switch on
what if you said Okay I want to make
let's just say a hundred thousand
dollars a year or a million it doesn't
make a difference and I asked you
what do you need to believe about
yourself
to achieve it so I need to believe I'm
smart enough good write down I am smart
enough what else do you need to believe
I need to believe that I am worthy I
need to believe that I deserve this I
need to believe that it's possible I
need to believe you write down five or
six or seven beliefs or just words on a
sheet of paper
now let me stop for just a moment I'm
going to tell a story and come back to
this I want you to imagine that somebody
tapped you on the shoulder sometime
today and say hey
um I work with Steven Spielberg and Tom
Hanks in Hollywood and we have this new
script okay that if you get really good
at this script where you could read it
in front of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks
now I want you to imagine you've never
seen the script you don't know how to
act but they said to you we're going to
give you an acting coach we're going to
give you everything you need to memorize
the script we're going to do everything
you need to act it perfectly what would
you do to take that script that's on a
piece of paper that you've never seen
before what would you do to take that
script
to make it yours for you to own it and
the answer is you probably read it like
what once uh would you read it maybe a
hundred times 200 times 500 times you
think you might role play with somebody
while you're holding the script in your
hand do you think you might research the
role do you think you might take a
camera and practice it and do you think
that if you practice it one time 50
times 100 times 500 times you can
finally put the script down and you can
get in front of the camera and go boom
here is the script do you think you
could do that well guess what a script
that's on a piece of paper that you
don't believe with practice you start to
believe so what happens if you take a
belief
system and you start to imprint it into
your subconscious mind initially through
conscious repetition but there are ways
to access the subconscious mind that we
know today that are faster and easier
than just doing it consciously and so
you take a vision of you achieving your
goals and dreams you take the beliefs
you need you learn how to manage your
emotions a little bit better and then
you develop the habits which again are
nothing more than neural patterns in the
brain that have been reinforced and when
you learn how to deactivate the
destructive ones and activate
constructive ones through space
repetition and reinforcement now you are
resetting your default way of being so a
belief is nothing more than a reinforced
pattern that if you learn how to
deactivate it and create a new one it's
like a software upgrade for your brain
all we have which everybody talks about
is this this moment this this precious
second right now so the more I could be
here right now
the more I'm living you know my the life
that I want to live
I don't want to talk to too much about
the future too much about the past that
can use those as something to you know
hope for in the future as a guiding post
from the past
um but right now is the moment that
every one of us has so if you take
any event that's occurred in the past if
you just merely think of that event
that's occurred in the past chances are
you're firing off the neural network of
that pattern right so you can take
um uh the idea of eating your favorite
dessert what do you think is happening
in your brain when you pretend you're
eating that favorite dessert of yours
and your mouth starts to water and you
start to feel oh that's such a great
dessert that's neurons in your brain
firing in the neurochemistry that is
associated with that memory firing now
let's say
that you have a disempowering pattern of
being embarrassed or ashamed or
ridiculed but instead of just thinking
about the pattern oh I don't like it as
soon as you think about the pattern and
it has a I'm going to say a
disempowering or negative emotion
chances are that means that the stress
Center in the brain has been activated
that means that your heartbeat's going
to go up that means that your sweat
glands are going to be activated that
means you're going to breathe a little
bit less uh uh deeply I mean more
shallowly
and that is the fear or stress response
now what if instead of allowing that to
continue you just stopped
and you had this intention
I'm going to dissolve the effectiveness
or the strength of this pattern how do
you do that well first and foremost you
stop you sit and you start with inner
size number one that actually I guide
you through in the book
all right and enter size number one
is called take six calm the circuits so
you want to move from your stress and
react system
to your relax and respond system you
have
parasympathetic and sympathetic nervous
systems okay that are triggered within
the body so what happens when you sit
quietly and you take six deep breaths in
through your nose
and out through your mouth like you're
blowing out through a straw when you do
it six times in 10 second rhythmic
breaths
and you focus on the air that you're
blowing out through your mouth like
you're blowing out through a straw that
simple inner size
is inner size number one take six calm
the circuits it actually deactivates the
stress fear embarrassment shame guilt
circuit
and in a quiet relaxed state
that same memory does not have the same
power
but if you don't do it in that state you
do it in a in a tense stressful State
you're actually reinforcing that pattern
versus thinking about bringing up that
old memory and doing this repetitively
10 times 20 times 30 times 40 times
until the neurons really don't fire that
strength at that strength level if
somebody has you know a fear like where
is that fear you know if I have a fear
of spiders and you don't then that means
that it's not the spider okay that's the
issue it's the meaning the pattern that
I have and the associations I have with
let's say spiders that's the issue well
where is that pattern well it's in my
non-conscious brain it's in my brain
well what if I can disrupt that pattern
using technology what if I can disrupt
that pattern using a variety of
evidence-based methodologies whether
it's cognitive behavior therapies that
you listen to and you participate in
well that is what we're doing we're just
helping people access the parts of their
brain where the patterns exist disrupt
the pattern help them create a new
pattern so that the fear goes away the
emotion of fear is an effect
right it's it's the feeling
so if we disrupt the pattern we disrupt
the unpleasant feeling that we call fear
so we've learned a variety of different
ways that are all based in neuroscience
and neuropsychology to disrupt patterns
create new patterns faster than ever
before so that people start to feel
better about themselves and about
anything that they want to achieve in
their life if you want another amazing
John ashtraf clip check it out right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there